[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
wenn es mal wieder länger dauert dann
tagt die EU es ist aber auch ein
schwieriges Thema bei dem die Interessen
und Haltungen sehr weit auseinander
liegen Mitgliedsländer und
eu-kommissionen haben heute erneut einen
Anlauf ihrer Asylpolitik zu reformieren
gestritten wird darüber ja seit Jahren
gleichzeitig sind die Zahlen der
flüchtenden wieder gestiegen bei den
Vorschlägen die heute auf dem Tisch
schlagen ging es vor allem darum
Menschen die eh kaum Chancen auf eine
asylanerkennung haben von einer Einreise
abzuhalten vor dem Treffen der EU
Innenminister in Luxemburg wurden hohe
Erwartungen geführt man hoffe auf einen
Durchbruch den gab es dann am Abend
schließlich auch nach zehn Verhandlungen
Isabel Schäfers berichtet
anyone
es herrscht fast ein gewisser Unglaube
im Raum als diese Abstimmung tatsächlich
durchgeht nach jahrelangem Ringen
einigen sich die EU Innenminister heute
auf einer asyl-reform
[Applaus]
ein starkes Signal wenn wir uns
zusammentun und Entscheidungen treffen
die nicht einfach aber notwendig sind
necessary und doch schnell wird klar in
dieser Erfolg ist wohl eher ein
europäischer Minimalkonsens ich möchte
gerne eine Protokollnotiz anfügen
Deutschland Irland Luxemburg und
Portugal weisen darauf hin dass uns
Ausnahmen
vom grenzverfahren für Minderjährige und
ihre Familienangehörigen sehr wichtig
sind
und bleiben in den trialogverhandlungen
werden wir uns weiter dafür einsetzen es
geht um sogenannte grenzverfahren an den
Außengrenzen für Flüchtlinge die
kaumchancen auf Asyl haben letztes Jahr
wurden in der EU insgesamt rund
885.000 Asylanträge gestellt und davon
kamen rund
227.000 aus Ländern mit einer
Anerkennungsquote unter 20%. dieses gute
viertel der Asylbewerber soll nach dem
neuen System in ein grenzverfahren
kommen über ihre Asylanträge würde dann
besonders schnell an den Außengrenzen
entschieden es ist einfach nicht fair
die Menschen so lange im Ungewissen zu
lassen wie er Asylverfahren ausgeht
besser sie bekommen schnell Klarheit und
können dann zurückgehen
außerdem sieht die asylreform vor
Solidarität verpflichten zu machen
anerkannte Asylbewerber sollen
umverteilt werden wer nicht aufnimmt
muss zahlen Ungarn und Polen verweigern
das
unserer Meinung nach ist das eine
Rückschritt wenn wir gezwungen werden
Flüchtlinge aufzunehmen oder ansonsten
eine Strafe zahlen müssen dann können
wir das unseren Bürgern nicht erklären
und somit auch nicht zustimmen
alle die diese Reform durchbringen
wollten mussten heute Zugeständnisse
machen zu viele Zugeständnisse finden
Kritiker vor allem in Deutschland
der Ampelkoalition wenn Sie diesen Weg
geht
Horst Seehofer hätte die Maßnahmen nicht
härter formulieren können als das was
jetzt vorliegt ist ein wirklich
schlechte Vorschläge handwerklich
schlecht gemacht nicht kohärent und sie
wickeln
menschenrechtsschutzstandards um Jahre
zurück doch ein erneutes Scheitern der
eu-asylreform sollte hier heute um fast
jeden Preis verhindert werden
und die bundesinnenministerin ist uns
ausfluxemburg zugeschaltet guten Abend
Frau Fähre
genau
wenn Menschenrechtsorganisationen sagen
härtere Maßnahmen hätte auch Horst
Seehofer nicht formulieren können ficht
sie das an als Sozialdemokratin
nein überhaupt nicht weil wir heute ein
historisches Ergebnis erreichen konnten
was vielen Jahrzehnte zuvor nicht
gelungen ist nämlich indem wir ein
gemeinsames europäisches Asylsystem auf
den Weg gebracht haben und Deutschland
hat dafür gesorgt dass Menschen schon
Rechtsstandards eingehalten werden wir
haben zum Beispiel dafür gesorgt dass
unbegleitete Minderjährige nicht in
grenzverfahren müssen wir haben dafür
gesorgt dass auch an den grenzverfahren
die ja nur für die Menschen gelten die
eine gewinnschutzquote haben und in die
EU kommen dass dort auch die
Menschenrechtsstandards alle eingehalten
werden wir haben heute viel Schlimmeres
verhindert und insofern bin ich sehr
froh und sehr stolz dass uns das
insgesamt mit einer sehr großen Mehrheit
doch gelungen ist am Ende Sprachen
gerade davon dass Minderjährige da nicht
betroffen sind aber diese Forderung die
Deutschland hatte dass der Familien mit
Kindern und Minderjährige außen vor
gelassen werden von diesen Lagern die es
dann künftig geben soll für die
Schnellverfahren das steht doch in dem
Kompromiss gar nicht mehr drin oder habe
ich mich da verlesen
es sind zwei Punkte das eine sind die
unbegleiteten Minderjährigen unter 18
die sind nicht drinnen im grenzverfahren
das haben wir raushalten können dass
seine Erfolg Deutschlands mit wenigen
anderen Staaten wie Portugal oder
Luxemburg das haben wir durchgesetzt was
wir nicht durchsetzen konnten ist dass
wir Familien mit kleinen Kindern in die
grenzverfahren reinbringen wie gesagt
gelten alle Menschenrechtsstandards und
man muss überlegen wie viele Menschen
betrifft das eigentlich weil es gilt nur
für eine geringe schutzquote bei
Menschen die zu uns kommen das heißt
Menschen aus Syrien Afghanistan mit
ihren Familien sind davon nicht
betroffen meistens sind Menschen die aus
Ländern mit geringer schutzpunkte zu uns
einwandern nicht als Familie unterwegs
aber es war ja ein wichtiger Punkt für
die Grünen aber eben auch für SPD
Abgeordnete da ist ja nicht so dass
Werder sich einer einer Meinung sind und
sie da alle ihre Leute hinter sich haben
wird das nicht ein Problem damit jetzt
zurück nach Berlin zu kommen zu sagen
Leute an der Stelle musste ich leider
diese Pille schlucken
ich glaube vor Slomka das gehört zu
Verhandlungen dazu dass man wenn man so
einen wirklichen historischen Konsens
hinbekommen möchte mit 27 europäischen
Staaten dass man an der einen Stelle
nachgeben muss an anderen Stelle aber
auch ganz viel bekommen wir haben heute
sehr viel bekommen wir haben einen
Ruanda Modell verhindern können also das
heißt mit in Drittstaaten Asylverfahren
durchzuführen außerhalb der EU das haben
wir verhindern können wir haben sehr
viele Menschenrechtsstandards eingezogen
wir haben die unbegleiteten
minderjährigen rausbekommen also
viel vorzuweisen und ja das gehört dazu
wenn ich dabei den Drittstaaten kurz
einen Haken darf diese Ruanda Regel ja
das heißt dass dann wird auch sogar
Asylverfahren in einem anderen Staat wie
zum Beispiel Ruanda der mit diesen
Leuten eigentlich gar nichts zu tun hat
durchgeführt wie die Briten das machen
aber es gibt ja noch eine andere
Drittstaaten Regelung nämlich das
nachdem man Asylverfahren hier abgelehnt
wurde dass man dann in einen Drittstaat
abschieben kann das ist doch weiterhin
drin oder das heißt die Reiseroute ist
dann eigentlich entscheiden und nicht so
sehr ob man in Asylgrund hat
nein also bei einem Asylverfahren ist
natürlich erstmal entscheidend der
Asylgrund wenn ein Asylgrund vorliegt
dann gilt es auch weiterhin es ist das
Asylrecht überhaupt nicht beschnitten
worden wenn Menschen wieder zurückkehren
müssen dann ist es möglich in Staaten
abzuschieben wohin die Menschen einen
Bezug haben also es ist nicht einfach
möglich nur wegen Transfer irgendwo
hinzukommen sondern es muss einen Grund
dafür geben und auch das haben wir heute
durchsetzen können das Problem der
Abschiebungen manche dann ist dann etwas
freundlicher Rückführungen das bleibt ja
erhalten wenn Herkunftsländer nicht
bereit sind zurückzunehmen oder wenn es
keine Drittstaaten gibt die sagen ja
okay die Leute sind von hier aus
abgereist die nehmen wir wieder dann
funktionieren ja die Abschiebungen nicht
besser als vorher also bevor diesen
Kompromiss der heute geschlossen wurde
das ist richtig aber das Wichtige ist ja
dass jetzt 27 europäische Staaten
gemeinsam auch mit Drittstaaten darüber
verhandeln können dass auch geflüchtete
die leider nicht bei uns bleiben können
wieder zurückkehren müssen das hat
natürlich ein ganz anderes Gewicht die
Kommission steht dahinter insofern wird
das sicherlich erfolgreicher sein als
vorher weil einfach ein ganz anderes
Gewicht nämlich jetzt der gesamten
europäischen Staaten dahinter steht als
wenn das nur Nationalstaaten probieren
sie betonen jetzt die Gemeinsamkeit ganz
wichtig ist wir konnten sie betonen
jetzt die Gemeinsamkeit aber wenn ich
das richtig sehe dann haben ja auch
Staaten dagegen gestimmt also Polen
Ungarn ist das was man jetzt ist ja
gerade noch ganz frisch lesen konnte
sind mit diesem Kompromiss nicht dabei
werden die denn dann trotzdem bei den
Regeln mitmachen und auch bei der
Verteilung mitmachen
ich gehe davon aus dass sie mitmachen
müssen das ist ja dann geltendes Recht
das ist in der Tat so dass Polen und
Ungarn die einzigen Staaten sind die mit
Nein gestimmt haben es gab dann noch
drei Enthaltung von Malta das Slowakei
Bulgarien aber alle anderen Staaten
haben mit javotiert und das ist wirklich
ein starkes Signal und das wird uns auch
helfen das wird uns vor allen Dingen
helfen auch ein Europa der offenen
Grenzen zu bewahren das war mir
persönlich immer sehr wichtig ich habe
sehr dafür gekämpft heute wir haben ja
einen langen Tag gehabt viele Beratung
und ich bin froh dass wir uns soweit
durchsetzen konnten und Länder die nicht
bereit sind geflüchtete aufzunehmen
können die sich dann frei kaufen
sozusagen das stand ja auch zu Debatte
es gibt eine Regelung dass diejenigen
die nicht mehr in der Lage sind
aufzunehmen und nicht aufnehmen wollen
auch Geld bezahlen können aber ich gehe
davon aus dass ich eine weitere
Solidarität in den EU-Staaten jetzt
durchsetzen wird weil jetzt haben wir
erstmals ein gemeinsames Asylsystem was
so umfassend ist wir haben ja auf der
einen Seite Regelungen für die
Registrierung an den Außengrenzen wir
haben einen festen
solidaritätsmechanismus ein Fall
verteilmechanismus und das sind einfach
strengere und Ordnung Regeln als wir sie
bislang hatten und deswegen hoffe ich
auch und ich gehe auch davon aus dass
wir viel dafür tun dass ich alle Staaten
dann auch daran halten das wird sich
natürlich in der Praxis dann zeigen aber
die Voraussetzungen sind gute dafür
haben sie keine Sorge das ist dann
demnächst Bilder geben wird wie wir sie
aus dem Flüchtlingslager Morea aus aus
lesboskanten wo furchtbare Zustände
herrschten und das ganze gestern auch
noch in Form von Internierungslagern die
man nicht mal mehr verlassen darf
wissen sie genau der Grund warum ich
heute so dafür gekämpft habe dass wir
Menschenrechtsstandards einziehen und
das eben alle an den Außengrenzen
beteiligten Staaten sich bereit erklärt
haben in humanitäre grenzverfahren zu
gehen und nicht mehr den Zustand den wir
jetzt haben zu tolerieren es ist eine
Verbesserung gegenüber dem ist Zustand
und das ist das Wichtige was heute
rausgekommen ist sagt die
bundesinnenministerin danke für das
Gespräch
danke Ihnen
das Interview haben wir vor einer halben
Stunde direkt nach der Einigung in
Luxemburg aufgezeichnet dass die
Flüchtlingsfrage politische Wahlen
beeinflussen kann war es nicht nur die
in Hessen wahlkämpfende
bundesinnenministerin väsern
insbesondere in den ostdeutschen
Bundesländern sichert das Thema der AFD
aktuell wieder hohen Zulauf der
politische Druck ist entsprechend hoch
letztlich geht es in den Städten und
Gemeinden aber vor allem darum
praktische Probleme zu lösen davon gibt
es reichlich aber auch Menschen die
anpacken Thomas Bersch mit Eindrücken
aus Dresden
kaleid armer kam vor 40 Jahren aus
Ägypten in die damalige DDR studierte
hier und leitet heute eine
Flüchtlingsunterkunft in der Dresdner
Neustadt und das weitgehend ohne
Probleme und in der Neustadt ist so viel
Kultur und Multikulti sozusagen
vor allem weil sie das in anderen
Ortsteilen auch schon einmal anders hört
sie managt als Beigeordnete der Stadt
den Flüchtlings Zuzug der auch Dresden
seit Monaten in Atem hält denn
preiswerte Wohnungen gibt es in ganz
Dresden keine mehr und neue bauen geht
auch gerade nicht so leicht
auch hier stehen wir vor der
Herausforderung dass wir kaum
Liegenschaften haben die aktiviert
werden können das kontinuierlich die
Preise steigen die Baukosten im Grunde
genommen durch die Decke schießen weil
die Flüchtlingszahlen in Dresden seit
zwei Jahren wieder rasant steigen kommt
die Stadt an logistische Grenzen sie
müssen Flüchtlinge aus manchen
Unterkünften auf der einen Elbseite zum
Beispiel zur Verpflegung auf die andere
Elbseite und zurück das ganze mittags
und abends zweimal täglich also anders
geht es nicht außerdem plant die Stadt
mit containerdörfern wie dieses hier das
treibt regelmäßig Anrainer auf die
Straße so wie hier im sogenannten
Dresdener Hochland 2015 protestierten
Einwohner gegen eine Unterkunft in
Pappritz sie hatten Angst ihre Autos vor
dem Hotel zu parken berichten Mitglieder
einer willkommensinitiative doch das war
damals und heute sieht es so aus dass
zum großen Teilen die Normalität
eingezogen ist das heißt die die Leute
parken ihr Auto ganz normal da auch zur
Bushaltestelle gehen die Leute ganz
normal und da steht da Asylbewerber oder
der Flüchtling genauso neben den
normalen wartenden die Lager hat sich
also weitgehend beruhigt doch die
engagierten Hochländer kommen schwerer
an die Heimbewohner heran als 2015 der
Grund anders als damals wohnen heute
hier viele ohne Bleibeperspektive sie
leben also hier und müssen damit rechnen
dass sie aber trotzdem jede Nacht
abgeholt werden
also das ist eine hohes stresspotenzial
was dort im Gange ist was auch nicht
gerade den Beitrag zur Integration ist
Dresden wäre geholfen könnte sich die
Stadt auf die konzentrieren die auch
hier bleiben dürften es sind unangenehme
Wahrheiten doch sie werden ausgesprochen
und ein anderen muss man sagen ja dieser
Zugang der humanitär gegeben ist der
steht euch leider nicht zu versucht über
Arbeitsmigration versucht es einfach auf
anderen Wege aber die
flüchtlingsgesetzgebung erfüllt ja
aktuell nicht ja die Diskussion in der
EU zum Thema in Dresden wird sie sicher
verfolgt
hintergründe und Infos zu den Debatten
über eine asyrreform finden Sie bei uns
natürlich auch online auf ZDF heute
mit einem anderen großen Reformvorhaben
geht es jetzt den Nachrichten weiter
Heinz die umstrittene Wahlrechtsreform
zur Verkleinerung des Bundestags kann in
Kraft treten Bundespräsident Steinmeier
hat das von Bundestag und Bundesrat
verabschiedete Gesetz dazu unterzeichnet
derzeit hat der Bundestag 736
Abgeordnete das neue Wahlrecht deckelt
die Zahl der Sitze bei 630 die Union
aber auch die Linke fühlt sich durch die
Reform benachteiligt und hält sie für
nicht mit dem Grundgesetz vereinbar
gewählt wird weiter mit erst und
Zweitstimme es gibt aber keine Überhang
und Ausgleichsmandate mehr für die
Stärke einer Partei im Parlament ist
allein ihr Zweitstimmenergebnis
entscheidend und auch die
grundmandatsklausel fällt weg nach ihr
zogen Parteien bisher auch dann in der
Stärke ihres zweitstimmenergebnisses in
den Bundestag ein wenn sie unter der 5%
Hürde lagen aber mindestens drei
Direktmandate gewonnen
in Moskau hat ein Prozess gegen den
bekannten Bürgerrechtler und
co-vorsitzenden der
Menschenrechtsorganisation Memorial Olek
Orloff begonnen der Vorwurf des
Kreditierung der russischen Armee Orloff
hatte unter anderem in einem Artikel auf
einer französischen Internetseite
Russlands Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine kritisiert bei einer
Verurteilung drohen ihm mehrere Jahre
Haft
US-Präsident beiden und der britische
Premierminister sunack haben bei einem
Treffen in Washington die
Gemeinsamkeiten zwischen beiden Ländern
betont seit Sonax Amtsantritt im Oktober
haben sich beide schon mehrfach
getroffen jetzt aber zum ersten Mal in
weißen Haus gesprochen wurde über die
Ukraine und auch über Wirtschaft und
technologische Fortschritte wie
künstliche Intelligenz
schwere Waldbrände in Kanada haben für
massive Luft Verschmutzung an der
US-Ostküste gesorgt für mehrere
Bundesstaaten meldete die
US-Umweltbehörde gefährlich hohe Werte
wegen der dichten Rauchschwaden war das
öffentliche Leben teils massiv
eingeschränkt unter anderem in der
Millionenstadt New York die Behörden
warnten die Menschen davor sich im
Freien aufzuhalten bereits seit Wochen
wüten im Westen und Nordosten Kanadas
zahlreiche Waldbrände
bei einem Brand in einem Bahntunnel in
Tirol sind 33 Zugreisende leicht
verletzt worden darunter zwei deutsche
betroffen war ein Nachtzug der
Österreichischen Bundesbahn der von
Innsbruck in Richtung Hamburg unterwegs
war nach ersten Erkenntnissen fiel im
rund 15 km langen Terre ferner Tunnel
bei Innsbruck eine defekte Oberleitung
auf einen Waggon auf dem Autos
transportiert wurden zwei Autos Finger
daraufhin Feuer die Einsatzkräfte
brachten etwa 150 Menschen aus dem
stehen gebliebenen Zug in Sicherheit
und dann blicken wir in die Ukraine von
mehreren Frontabschnitten im Süden und
Osten des Landes werden heftige Kämpfe
gemeldet noch unklar ob das bereits der
Beginn der ukrainischen Offensive ist
oder eher Vorbereitungen daraufhin dem
die ukrainische Armee die russischen
Stellungen unter Druck setzt und nach
Schwachstellen zu sucht auch Leopard
Panzer sollen im Einsatz sein
klar ist aber auch dass die Staudamm
Katastrophe viele ukrainische Kräfte
bindet und dabei werden Flutopfer und
Hilfskräfte auch noch beschossen unsere
Reporterin Alisa jung hat das den Hassan
selbst erlebt
von hier starten die Helfer um die
rauszuholen die noch immer
eingeschlossen sind vom Wasser darunter
Niels Tal ein Feuerwehrmann aus Nürnberg
freigestellt vom Dienst und seit Monaten
in der Ukraine um zu helfen das ist so
dass wir zu wenig Boote haben zu wenig
also Schlauchboote mit Motoren wir
brauchen auch mehr Watt watthosen wir
brauchen
Rettungswesten wir brauchen dringend
Material und das brauchen wir jetzt und
nicht in zwei Wochen die Zeit läuft
gegen sie so viele sitzen noch fest vor
allem im russisch besetzten Gebiet es
fehlt ein Trinkwasser und Nahrung die
ukrainische Armee zeigt auf diesen
Bildern wie sie versuchen aus der Luft
zu helfen mit Drohnen mir jetzt Tal
bricht auf zu seinem nächsten Einsatz
fest entschlossen furchtlos doch dann
Schüsse auf das Evakuierungsgebiet Nils
und auch wir müssen uns in Sicherheit
bringen
das ist einer der wenigen geöffneten
Bunker bzw ein Keller hier in Hessen
eben gerade haben wir Einschläge gehört
und sind dann jetzt hier runtergegangen
die können entweder nur ganz kurz dauern
oder über mehrere Stunden haben die
Menschen uns erzählt die hier aktuell
versuchen noch immer eingeschlossene zu
retten Nils erreichen wir am Telefon
möchte
dann gleich wieder weiter
daraus wird nichts
über Stunden dauert der Angriff
mindestens neun Menschen werden verletzt
ein Mensch getötet unter den Verletzten
auch ein anderer Helfer aus Deutschland
sagt uns das Krankenhaus in Hassan wo
noch kurz vor dem Angriff der Präsident
persönlich den Helfern Mut macht und
Hilfe verspricht
es mangelt an Ärzten in unserem Land
viele sind wegen des Krieges weggegangen
wir werden Ihnen hier vor Ort helfen wir
sind dankbar für ihre Arbeit sie sind
Helden
und meint Menschen wie Nils
gibt es viele Menschen die hier seit
mehr als einem Jahr in diesem Krieg
helfen und ich bin erst seit eineinhalb
Monaten hier
er will bleiben wie auch immer es in den
nächsten Wochen weitergeht
und schalten wir noch zu unserem
Reporter in der Ukraine Tim Kröger
derzeit noch in Hassan Tim was hörst du
denn von den Kämpfen an der Front bzw
den Fronten offenbar versucht die
Ukraine ja an mehreren Abschnitten
vorzustoßen
ja also es ist sehr schwer dich ein
klares Bild von der Situation an der
Front zu machen allein schon deswegen
weil auch die ukrainische Seite sich mit
genauen Informationen sehr bedeckt hält
immerhin hat die ukrainische
stellvertretende Verteidigungsministerin
heute bestätigt das ist Kämpfe im Süden
des Landes gibt das ist auch Kämpfe gibt
in der Region sapricia und dass da dort
ganz offenbar die russischen
Streitkräfte in der Defensive sind die
russische Seite wiederum sagt ja es gab
eine offensive dort aber die ist
zurückgeschlagen worden beides können
wir natürlich nicht überprüfen aber es
deutet zumindest sehr klar darauf hin
dass dort heftig gekämpft wird und dass
dort die Ukraine ganz offenbar in die
Offensive vorgegangen ist und ähm jetzt
wissen wir natürlich nicht ob das jetzt
schon der Beginn dieser Offensive ist
wir haben ja auch schon am Montag
offensiv Aktion der ukrainischen Seite
gesehen das müssen wir einfach abwarten
interessant ist aber dieser Ort wo jetzt
dieser neue Vorstoß ganz offenbar
stattfindet nämlich südlich von das ist
genau der Ort wo viele Analysten und
auch Beobachter diese Gegenoffensive
oder den hauptschlag dieser
Gegenoffensive erwartet haben ganz
einfach weil die ukrainische Seite
versuchen könnte dort bis zu mehr
durchzustoßen und dann die
Landverbindung zwischen Russland und der
von Russland annektierten Halbinsel Krim
zu durchbrechen das wäre schon ein
relativ empfindlicher Schlag militärisch
gesehen für die russische Seite aber
auch das ist noch kein wirklich
gesicherter Hinweis dass es allenfalls
ein Indiz das womöglich diese Offensive
begonnen hat wissen tun wir es nicht
danke dir Einschätzung
wenn sie helfen wollen das
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe
unterstützt die Menschen in
Überschwemmungsgebiet spenden können Sie
unter dem Stichwort ZDF Nothilfe Ukraine
die waren de
6500 alle Infos finden Sie auch unter
spenden.zdf.de oder im ZDF Text auf
Seite 890
in Frankreich herrscht Entsetzen über
den Messerangriff heute morgen in einem
Park am Lack deinesi einem beliebten
Feriengebiet in den französischen Alpen
ein Mann nach Polizeiangaben einen
geflüchtete aus Syrien attackierte dort
eine Gruppe Kleinkinder und ihrer Eltern
fünf Menschen wurden verletzt teils
schwer
unser Frankreich
auf diesem Spielplatz hier hinter mir
soll der Täter ganz gezielt auf kleine
Kinder eingestochen haben laut
Medienberichten hat er sich während der
Tat als Christ bezeichnet die Behörden
können das so nicht bestätigen aber sie
sagen es gebe keinen Hinweis auf einen
terroristisches Motiv sie sagen der Mann
aber zuvor in Schweden gelebt habe dort
sah dort als Flüchtling anerkannt worden
sei vor einigen Monaten erst nach
Frankreich gekommen und hier den
Sicherheitsbehörden nicht aufgefallen er
habe hier in Frankreich noch einmal ein
Asylverfahren angestrengt dass er aber
abgelehnt worden eben mit Hinweis darauf
dass man ja bereits einen
Flüchtlingsstatus habe diese Ablehnung
habe er vor vier Tagen bekommen ob es da
einen Zusammenhang gibt dazu wollen
Behörden nicht sagen die
Premierministerin Elisabeth bauen war
heute hier und sagte er noch zu früh
jetzt politische Schlussfolgerungen zu
ziehen die Opposition von marien le
Penis national hat in das sofort
umgehend europäisches Asylrecht
kritisiert am Abend haben hier wir haben
es gesehen einige Rechtsextremisten
demonstriert die Polizei hat sie
umgehend das Ortes verwiesen danke schön
Thomas Walde für diese Information
und dann geht es jetzt bei dir noch mal
weiter Hans mit Wirtschaftsthemen da gab
es heute eine interessante Meldung ja
damit Europa im Bereich der
Mikroelektronik und Chips unabhängige
von China und den USA wird hat die EU
ein milliardenschweres beihilfeprogramm
genehmigt das betrifft auch eine Reihe
von Projekten in Deutschland von
Wittmann wie wichtig ist diese Förderung
ja sehr wichtig es sei ein
industriepolitischer Meilenstein
kommentierte Wirtschaftsminister Habig
am Nachmittag das Go aus Brüssel damit
könnten die Beteiligten deutschen Firmen
unter ihnen Infineon oder Boschen und
loslegen 10 Milliarden Euro will die
heimische Industrie investieren unter
anderem für den Bau von
Fertigungsstätten und für die
Entwicklung von modernen Halbleiterchips
dabei sollen die Firmen mit 4 Milliarden
Euro gefördert werden zu 70% vom Bund
und zu 30% von den Ländern der
Branchenverband BITCOM begrüßte die
Entscheidung Beamte aber zugleich zur
Eile die Genehmigung der EU habe viel
Zeit in an aufgenommen viele Projekte
stünden seit mehr als einem Jahr in den
Startlöchern an den 31 Projekten in elf
Bundesländern sein auch kleine und
mittelständische Unternehmen sowie
Start-ups beteiligt ein Projekt fehlt
aber wurde von der Förderliste
gestrichen warum ja das ist interessant
das war mal 32 nicht auf der aktuellen
Förderliste steht der Chiphersteller
nexperia der zwar überwiegend in Hamburg
produziert und seinen Hauptsitz in den
Niederlanden hat aber eben auch ein
chinesischen Eigentümer mit guten
Verbindungen nach Peking und da haben
Harbeck und sein Ministerium gesagt dass
Unternehmen fördern wir nicht zumal wenn
es sich um Schlüsseltechnologien wie
Mikrochips handelt
Frank beetmann vielen Dank
Tennisprofi Tim Pütz hat überraschend
den mixtitel bei den French Open
gewonnen der 35 Jahre alte Frankfurter
setzte sich mit seiner japanischen
Spielpartnerin myokato im Finale in drei
Sätzen gegen Michael Wien ist aus
Neuseeland und Bianca Andrej
die deutsche Fußballnationalmannschaft
bereitet sich derzeit in Frankfurt am
Main auf das erste von drei anstehenden
Länderspielen vor am Nachmittag
absolvierte das Team von Bundestrainer
Hansi Flick ein erstes gemeinsames
Training zu dem auch 600 Zuschauer
zugelassen waren
Pokalsieger Timo Werner fällt für die
Partie am kommenden Montag gegen die
Ukraine live zu sehen im ZDF
wahrscheinlich mit einer Knöchel Blessur
aus es folgen dann noch zwei weitere
Tests gegen Polen und Kolumbien
das war's von uns gleich nach dem Wetter
geht es bei Maybrit Illner Walter sie
diskutiert mit ihren Gästen über die
Frage ob es im ukrainekrieg eine neue
Dimension gibt zu Gast sind unter
anderem grünen Chef um mit Nuri pur und
Klaus Kleber und um 0:30 Uhr gibt's dann
unsere heute schnell Update mit
Christopher Wehrmann und uns morgen
wieder auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute hat es ja richtig
gebrudelt in der Atmosphäre es gab
kräftige Schauer und Gewitter die werden
sich aber immer mehr verabschieden denn
das Team viel zieht weiter Richtung
Schwarzes Meer und das Hoch hier
erreicht morgen Abend bereits das
Baltikum was bleibt ist am Boden eine
ostströmung vier Sonnenschein und hohe
Temperaturen jetzt in der Nacht gibt es
vielleicht noch letzte Regenschauer
viele wird das aber nicht mehr sein
häufig ist es klar und die Temperaturen
sinken auf Werte zwischen 15 Grad am
Niederrhein und sechs Grad in
Schleswig-Holstein und morgen steigen
die Temperaturen an den Küsten von Nord
und Ostsee auf 19 bis 25 Grad im
Binnenland werden meist sommerliche 24
bis 30 Grad erreicht der Tag beginnt mit
sehr viel Sonne im Südosten bilden sich
schon die ersten Quellwolken und
nachmittags kann es dann einzelne
Regenschauer und Gewitter geben in
Sachsen im Bayerischen Wald vielleicht
aber auch mal in der Eifel oder im
Schwarzwald der Winter dazu kommt aus
östlichen Richtung und an diesem Wetter
ändert sich über das Wochenende hinaus
nichts es bleibt bei viel Sonnenschein
es gibt selten mal Regenschauer und
Gewitter bei Höchsttemperaturen zwischen
20 und 31 Grad und bis zum
astronomischen Sommerbeginn am 21 juni
wird sich daran auch in den
Millionenstädten also in Hamburg München
Köln und Berlin wenig ändern sie sehen
es gibt immer Temperaturen um die 25
Grad ich wünsche Ihnen noch einen
schönen Abend